Well church, this is another beautiful
picture of the gospel.
This is Gabe Jeter
and over the last couple months working with one
of our members and then having a family specifically be
praying for him over the last couple months, he's come
to realize just a few weeks ago, came forward
after his service, talked to one of our prayer partners and,
and shared, I just, I need Jesus.
And so this today is evidence of that.
It's not the only evidence,
but it is a part of what it means to follow Jesus,
to declare that publicly through baptism as a symbol,
another symbol of death to life
of what's happened spiritually.
And so Gabe, I get to baptize you, my friend.
What a gift it is on today, like today to hear
and to see this happen.
And so because of your profession of faith in Jesus,
I baptized you in the name of the Father, son
and Holy Spirit,
Listen, church, maybe,
maybe somebody is in the same place
Gabe was a few weeks ago.
We got prayer partners down here at the front.
As soon as we're done, men and women who'll be willing
and love the privilege to talk with you
and pray with you about that, about anything.
Maybe God's working on your heart with that guilt
and you need to find somewhere
that you can get some help walking outta that.
We'd love to help you with that.
So I pray for Gabe and pray for us as we leave today.
Lord, thank you so much for what you've done in Gabe's life
and how you have worked to bring him through
so many circumstances to a place to see you
and see his need for you,
and to be able to live now in a freedom that comes with
your blood, washing him clean spiritually.
I pray for each of us that we would walk in
that freedom today knowing that there is
so much the enemy can accuse us of.
But Jesus, you knew it all too, and you took it to the cross
and then to the grave,
and you came outta that grave alive
with victory over all of it.
So may we walk in that freedom today.
May we lean on each other towards the freedom
that you offer us knowing this is a hard battle,
but you're at work in us having already won that battle
to bring us home one day fully and completely purified.
Grateful God bless us. Send us for your glory.
In Jesus' name, amen. Amen. Amen. Love you church.
We are sent.
Amen.